وعبد الحفيظ جعوان معنى الان مباشره عبر
الهاتف همم عبد الحفيظ اهلا بك معناها
الرشحت المزيد من المعلومات حول همم اطلاق
النار في مستوطنه همم نفي يعقوب او النبي
يعقوب في القدس
يدور عن عشره اصابات على الاقل خمسه منها
بحاله خطيره على ما يبدو ان منفذ او منفذ
الهجوم غير واضح حتى هذه اللحظه كامله
على مجموعه من المستوطنين في المكان بعدها
طاردتهم همم سياره شرطه اسرائيليه كانت
موجوده في المكان همم الشرطه الاسرائيليه
تتحدث عن اصابه ربما احد المنفذين بجروح
خطيره وغير معروف حتى هذه اللحظه كان هناك
ممثلا اخر قد لدى الفراغ عمليا حاله من
الهلع الكبيره الشرطه الاسرائيليه تقوم في
هذه اللحظات باغلاق همم المطارق واغلاق
الطرق في المكان في محاوله
لفهم ما جرى اولا ثم نقل الاصابات ومعاينه
الحدث اذا 10 اصابات حسبك اذا عبد الحفيظ
حتى الان في اطلاق النار في النبي يعقوب
معلومات قبل قليل ااه وكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه عبد الحفيظ قالت انه ااه جرى قتل
احد مطلقي النار لا نعلم هي تحدثت عن مطلق
نار واحد همم لكن داني اسالك عن ان ما في
يعقوب ماذا نعرف عن طبيعه المكان هذه
المستوطنه في القدس همم ما المعلومات
المتوفره عنها وطبيعه همم التواجد السكاني
فيها والامني
لا مو حي استيطاني في الشرقيه مدينه القدس
بالقرب من بلده بيت حنينا الى شمال من
مدينه القدس يقتله عدد كبير من المستوطنين
وعمليا هي يعني منطقه ايضا يعيش بالقرب
منها عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين من
المقدسيين وعاده ما يجري يعني في هذا
المكان مناوشات بين الفلسطينيين وبين
المستوطنين مثل كل البلدات الموجوده في
مدينه القدس والاحياء الموجوده في مدينه
القدس وايضا مفرق وشريان طرق رئيسي يؤدي
من القدس الشرقيه الى اماكن مختلفه
وبالتالي عرفا ما يكون هناك
للمستوطنين في المكان كان الحديث اولا
يجري عن استهداف كنيس ايضا في
المكان في هذا الحيه الاصطلاني ولكن حتى
هذه اللحظه همم يعني غير معروف كيف تم
استهداف المستوطنين هل كانوا خارج الكنيسه
كانوا في الشارع همم
يعني في مكان اخر همم الان الاخبار
الاسرائيليه تتحدث ان المنفذ هو منفذ واحد
وعلى ما يبدو ان الشرطه الاسرائيليه همم
قامت بقتله والشرطه الاسرائيليه تقول الان
لا خوف من وجود منقبه اخر في المكان هذه
طبعا الاخبار التي رشحت حتى هذه اللحظه
وما زال طبعا الاخبار تريد تباعا عن
العمليه طيب همم الوضع ما يزال ولكن في
نبي يعقوب الوضع همم
مرتبك قليلا يمكن القول او بعد هذه
الاخبار يمكن الحديث على همم يعني عوده
الهدوء
لا هو كان متوقع هذه العمليات صهيب كانت
متوقعه وخصوصا هي مرتبطه بشكل اساسي بما
جرى البارحه في مدينه جنين نعم ما جرى في
مدينه الجنين وكان هناك تحضيرات بان
الفلسطينيين او بعض الخلايا الفلسطينيين
ستقوم بتنفيذ عمليات اطلاق نار ردا على
ضحايا العشر الذين بالرصاص الجيش
الاسرائيلي يوم امس وبالتالي هذا متوقع ان
هناك
القدس منذ 17 سنه
نعم خمسه قتله اسرائيليين والجرحى
خمسه قتل اسرائيليين وعلى ما يبدو ان هناك
قتلى
اسرائيليين في اطلاق نار من قبل همم
فلسطيني على ما يبدو ال- اللسنه متاكدين
بعد ولكن في العموم هو شخص مجهول على
العموم القوات الاسرائيليه قامت بقتله همم
كذلك في اطلاق النار في مستوطنه نبي يعقوب
او مصطفى النبي يعقوب في القدس احد احياء
همم القدس همم اذا همم مع العموم عبد
الحفي معاك بهذا القدر الان ولكن نبقي
عيوننا على هذا الخبر المتفاعل واي همم
تفاصيل ترشح عنه همم نعاود الاتصال بك في
نشرات هذا المساء شكرا لك عبد الحفيظ